s'intéresser s'occuper des jeunes d'il
ya vingt ans maintenant nous vous le
disions en ouverture de journal nous
allons célébrer ce soir et demain notre
manière le 20e anniversaire des
événements de mai 68 il faut savoir et
on le perçoit mieux aujourd'hui avec le
recul que les premiers frémissements de
ce mouvement sont apparus à strasbourg
mai 68 en fête a démarré deux ans avant
c'est ce que nous explique ce soir dans
ce premier volet paul kobe ch qui a
retrouvé de nombreux documents
d'archivés
strasbourg avait senti passer le vent de
la révolte bien avant nanterre et bien
avant la sorbonne dès 1966 une poignée
de reder influencé par quelques membres
de l'internationale situationniste et
par leurs thèses s'emparer de
l'association des étudiants de
strasbourg puis de la mnef
au moment de la rentrée solennelle les
doigts years et professeurs trouvèrent
sur leurs sièges ce texte devenu célèbre
et qui contenait un diagnostic
prophétique de tous ceux qui exploserait
deux ans plus tard
face au scepticisme est de beaucoup
alain différent de la plus grand nombre
au laisser-aller et au conformisme de
tous
il est certain qu'un groupuscule avis en
ayant bien ce levier pouvait faire
quelque chose et c'est ce qu'ils ont
fait pour laisser passer leurs idées
dans la foulée les situe comme on les
appelait alors dissolvent les pas pu les
bureaux des psychologies
qu'universitaire symbole pour eux de la
psychiatrie policière puis la braise se
mit à couver jusqu'au 5 mai 1968 date de
la première grève générale des
universités revendications libéré
cohn-bendit et les étudiants arrêtés
dans les bagarres qui avaient opposé à
paris les étudiants gauchistes et les
jeunes militants d'extrême droite
le lendemain les premières barricades
s'élève dans les rues du quartier latin
mais il faudra attendre le 8 mai pour la
première grande manifestation
strasbourgeoise
actuellement on en arrive à point de nom
le gouvernement nous accule à la révolte
il n'est plus question de revendiquer
quoi que ce soit sinon sinon une chose
qui a été définie dans la motion qui a
été voté ce matin à 7h par le conseil
étudiant occupant la faculté des lettres
c'est à dire l'autonomie diversité
pourtant les manifs ne seront pas le
fort des étudiants de strasbourg
vingt ans après celui que vous voyez ici
raconte je sais pas quel jour c'est et
je sais pas quand c'est exactement mais
en fait
il y avait peu de manifestations
d'ailleurs strasbourg à cette époque là
on était surtout dans le cadre du palais
u on n'avait pas le romantisme des
barricades à la parisienne
ce qui fait que vous font on avait une
chance quand même me nourris à
strasbourg je crois c'est que nous
étions un peu par l'inaction à
strasbourg
nous étions un peu con année je crois la
réflexion et strasbourg était je crois à
cette époque sans trop me tromper je
crois que strasbourg était un lieu où on
a beaucoup réfléchi
l'autonomie de l'université de
strasbourg devient en 24 heures le mot
d'ordre qui donnera quelques mois plus
tard la loi edgar faure
les étudiants avaient à leur insu fait
aboutir une réforme qu'il n'était de
loin pas les seuls à souhaiter
mais entre nous demander l'autonomie b y
compris le recteur nous étions tous
d'accord sur cette question de lui nous
demandons tous l'autonomie et encore
maintenant dans l'est dans la loi ou à
l'effort qui a été votée il ya
l'autonomie des universités le seul
ennui c'est que pour réaliser
l'automobie disons administratives aux
politiques
je dirais qu'il faut les moyens avec une
sans moyens et nous le verrons demain
l'autonomie ne suffira de loin pas à
assouvir la frénésie des étudiants
où est la vie va commencer
a admis que l'université de strasbourg
explore les possibilités d'une telle
autonomie et fasse des propositions pour
cette expérience
il aura fallu six jours et les combats
sanglants de la rue gay lussac pour
obtenir ce résultat
mais dès le lendemain les étudiants
empêcher la tenue du conseil
universitaire qui devait prendre acte de
la décision du ministère à peine obtenu
l'autonomie et est donc rejetée par ceux
qui détenaient alors le vrai pouvoir
car c'est là que j'ai compris
l'importance des médias en particulier
l'importance le micro dans une
révolution
tel est le micro si vous tenez le micro
vous tenez la foule les professeurs sont
restés partagés tout au long des
événements
même ceux qui avaient pris très tôt le
parti des étudiants même ceux là ont été
sidérés par la brutalité de l'événement
et parce qu'il signifiait le sentiment à
l'époque
d'abord le sentiment d'une un peu d'une
catastrophe
quel que soit celui de la d'une remise
en cause radicale d'autant plus radicale
je dire qu'on n'attendait pas et
qui faisait que tout d'un coup parce que
du fait du jour au lendemain dans la
seconde
l'un tout ce qui était une sorte
d'édifices s'écroulait et pourquoi
s'écroule et il parce qu'on avait le
sentiment que ça ne repose sur que des
conventions admise est comme ça de façon
implicite par chacun et qu'il n'y avait
aucune aucune contrainte autre que c'est
à l'accepter tout d'un coup on
s'apercevrait que tout cela n'était
qu'une sorte de château de cartes qui
s'écroule a été con on été remis en
cause de convives mandat et finalement
qu'est ce que vous faites vous en tant
qu'enseignant en alsace comme dans le
reste de la france cet écroulement
s'intensifier 9 millions de salariés
avaient cessé le travail
la paralysie du pays n'étaient plus
interrompu que par les manifestations et
les combats de rue de plus en plus dur
le 24 mai les pavés volet place du
corbeau un épisode plus symbolique que
dramatique
les étudiants de strasbourg ne se
fatiguer pas d'imaginer et de réfléchir
à deux pas du palais la frontière se
dresser comme les barreaux d'une prison
ridicule au qg des étudiants on ne
voyait pas d'issue et pour cause
même parmi les meneurs on croyait à tout
sauf à une révolution
certains d'entre eux en feront leur
philosophie et par la suite de la
politique
vie libre en avait dit un jour à propos
de son fils qu'on venait d'arrêter sur
les barricades à berlin communiste à 20
ans
social-démocrate cac 40 est ce que c'est
un peu votre destin et vous devez en 68
c'est vrai que j'ai participé d'assez
près à ces événements et j'ai découvert
la politique à vrai dire à ce moment là
je crois que sur le fond je n'ai pas
changé du tout c'est plutôt sûr
l'idée que je me fais tes
des moyens pour parvenir à ces objectifs
quand nous serons tout le monde
deux temps dès 'solides' légal
rossignol mêmes
manqué
le seront
ou s'en faut
le temps
les cerises où l'on s'en va de
cueillir en rêvant
des pendants d'oreilles
personne n'a rien compris à cette
situation de l'alsace qui a été une
explosion comment l'alsace qui
traditionnellement était la terre de la
tranquillité à l'autre guybet commencer
l'université de strasbourg qui explose
la première et faut bien le dire on sait
qu'à strasbourg les taupes
situationniste avait bien travaillé
depuis deux ans et les cours dispensés
par le sociologue marxiste henri
lefebvre n'ont pas été pour rien dans la
formation d'un noyau dur capable
d'exploiter la situation
pourtant le doyen livet a aussi
psychanalyse et mai 68
c'est à minuit en discutant avec
quelques étudiants qui cherchaient à
pénétrer dans la faculté de l'esplanade
il eu une illumination
[Musique]
alors nous avons fait ouvrir la porte et
j'ai à faire c'est au bonheur si vous
voulez et il nous voulons couchez vous
voulez coucher vous voulez rentrer
voulait coucher
oui ne voulant coucher juste une bonne
idée ça me bouffe et de la faculté vous
et moi de mon temps de convoyer plutôt
un bâtiment universitaire
on partait plutôt que d'y entrer
maintenant nous voulons coucher bakou
des seahawks est assis avec sa exemple
vous faire plaisir
je vais vous faire donné des couvertures
ah non surtout pas ça et c'est à ce
moment là que la lumière s'est fait de
mon esprit surtout pas ça jeudi
l'université c'est la mer
les professeurs l'ont épouser et vous
voulez remplacer le malheur des maris
c'est qu'ils perdaient bien autre chose
que la simple possession de l'alma mater
que n'a plus été possible de l'enseigné
de la même façon parce que on se rendait
compte que évidemment le savoir avait
été remis en cause si on devait être
plus attentifs à ce qui se passe que
l'on disait et à en savoir la la la
visée la fin de la fonction d'affilée
l'autorité ne faisait plus savoir et le
savoir ne faisait plus l'autorité on
peut résumer je pense que oui la formule
est assez bonne
du moins il fallait que le savoir
trouver les moyens de faire autorité par
par la cohérence plus grande et non pas
une espèce d'inspiration où je dirais de
droite donné droit divin que reste-t-il
de mai 68 pour certains professeurs
l'université reste plus menacé que
jamais mais plus par ses étudiants la
contestation est 9ème plus de
l'intérieur de l'université mais elle
vient j'irai me semble-t-il de de
l'extérieur enfin monde est en train de
demander de l'extérieur mais votre
savoir qu'est ce que vous en faites à
quoi il sert est ce que je crains
personnellement est ce qui n'était pas
le cas en 68 nous semble-t-il c'est
qu'on est en train de remettre en cause
je sais bien je veux dire un surtout le
savoir désintéressé pour moi mai 68 ça a
surtout apporté
une capacité d analyse politique et on a
gardé une certaine méfiance à l'égard
des pouvoirs et au fond je crois que
ceux qui en est resté c'est une sorte de
fond un peu anarchiste par rapport aux
par rapport au pouvoir politique
il reste aussi quand même l'idée que les
choses peuvent bouger
[Musique]